the jurogan experience yeah you're a
legitimate chocolate fiend
i'm definitely a legitimate job how much
do you eat a day how much chocolate do
you eat you know i
every single morning i have hot
chocolate and it takes about 45 minutes
of preparation time has about four
different
ingredients so i start that then i have
some chocolate over the course
45 minutes yeah a lot of it is simmering
so it's not really
fully active but it's some active and
some passive intervention so is this a
preparation that you do like is it
does it prepare you for the day is it
like a meditation thing
you know it's probably some kind of
morning ritual but it's just
i don't know it's very calming for me
and by the time after this 45 minutes
it's like
pudding i mean it's like this thick
bubbling hot chocolate it just it brings
me joy i feel like everyone should start
their day with joy
there's some like positive qualities and
it's not just a
good tasting thing right like oh
chocolate chocolate has some
again dark chocolate especially has all
kinds of very
positive health benefits i'm not saying
that everyone should just eat chocolate
bars all day and you're going to
live forever but actually the the world
the woman who lived
longest of everyone in recorded history
ate two pounds of
chocolate a week jean-claude mall in
france so at least
it could help two pounds seems excessive
it's a lot but she lived 122.
but but chocolate's different in terms
of like some chocolate is like really
sugar
sugar-based and some chocolate is more
of like kind of
i really like dark chocolate and peanut
butter together
you know chocolate bar yeah yeah or like
a reese's piece yeah so the the dark
chocolate
is the healthier version of chocolate on
on average and so these the darker pure
cacao that's where the
health benefits are but but some people
think there's like uh
there's some psychoactive benefits to
chocolate right to cacao there is a
little bit yeah well
so cacao has been used ceremonially for
about
5 000 years so there definitely is a
is a history of that and and it has some
i mean it's not
as psychoactive as some of the other
stuff you talk about on the show but
it has a little bit of it well we did a
podcast before the podcast while we're
getting covet-tested out there
yep yeah exactly exactly talking about
our experience last time yeah um and so
there's another thing that happens that
i was reading about
some people like chocolate because it
replaces
uh like it gives them a feeling of being
loved have you ever read that
i haven't read that but i mean maybe
it's true i don't know whether there's
something
i don't doubt there's something that's
chemical about chocolate but it's
i think there's probably an association
with chocolate and happiness and
everybody's
hope lots of people's grandma
grandmothers gave them little chocolate
so i think that there's a little bit of
that
maybe it's part of the chocolate maybe
it's part of ours i think it's like a
oh god i wish i could remember it see if
you can find this like
there's tryptophan on it really that's
what it is this article says it should
defend amino acids small quantities but
in a flavonoids is the
melanophene yeah does it have something
to do with uh
love what is what it says here oh this
is wow this is fast acting
chalk in the brain science behind
chocolate but okay there we go
butterflies we feel when falling in love
yeah wow all right
great well if the internet says it it
must be true must be
that was the idea that i had read that
some people like chocolate like when
they're depressed like
when they're heartbroken yeah they like
chocolate sort of a replacement
for love yeah i mean i definitely if
you're feeling bad
and you eat chocolate you're probably
going to feel better so maybe it is a
replacement in a little way
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience